i want to start this interview by
wishing you pascal a very happy mother's
day
thank you of course and i think it only
feels right that we extend a happy
mother's day to our girl rosemary at
this point
i know
oh we just watched episode 10 and we
know that rosemary is expecting a baby
[Music]
how are you feeling i'm really pleased
with that that it came to fruition i'm
happy with the story how it unfolds you
know after so much speculation for so
many seasons
from the fans it was gonna be really
hard to
uh keep it a secret like it was gonna be
hard storytelling wise to keep it a
secret have her have symptoms and not
have everybody
just assume right away and so it really
was just a speculation wait and see
and uh that's the journey of kind of
living in that i think i am but i don't
know rosemary and lee got married in
season three
kevin how are you feeling that now here
in season nine your character doesn't
know it yet but but speaking with with
the wisdom of kevin the actor how do you
feel about this storyline officially
happening
well
as much as i'd like to take credit for
it it really
really did not have much to do with me
pascal made that happen but no as far as
the storyline goes i think it was uh it
was a no-brainer it had to happen at
some point and i'm actually kind of glad
that we waited so long
because i think
it is a struggle for a lot of people i
kind of like that they had to go through
this fire first
um but really this is all
pascal she made this happen she was not
gonna let it go did you have a say in
the creative in how it all unfolds for
rosemary
yeah i had a lot of say and i i agree
with the choice
that
i i'm happy with how it unfolds that
even though the audience
knows and suspects
about it like right away i don't know
that there was any other way to do that
with
pregnancy symptoms our audience is
predominantly women they were going to
be like
spidey senses like
she's pregnant
and so
what i think though and i'm hoping is
the case
is that the fans will really enjoy
being in on the secret with rosemary
until lee finds out and you know i i
think it's so interesting because we've
always talked about how rosemary and lee
complete each other they are finishing
each other's sentences they are each
others yin and yang
and i just felt like oh my goodness i
couldn't believe that rosemary
learns she's pregnant and she doesn't
want to immediately go run to lee to
make him aware of it what did you make
of that
that choice that creative decision i
think what it does is it builds
that
suspense
and then it's such an
amazing cathartic
moment
when he does find out and
uh
that i think that that's really special
and
so that you hopefully get in this story
you hopefully get
both
the
vulnerability and
cautiousness of
am i pregnant is this real like you get
all that those emotions and that
vulnerability but you also then
ultimately get that
huge payoff of
just unbridled excitement and enjoyment
and like just happiness pure joy right
and kevin you've got a big old smile on
your face right now what can you tease
about how lee will react to this big
dream being fulfilled when i first heard
about the
the pause on that reveal i was like wait
wait wait wait wait no no no it has to
be
big it has to be special and like
keeping it from him i thought that that
would take away from that but it didn't
in the end the reveal
is such that it's
i love how it comes about i love where
we are it's very intimate just the two
of us which is what i wanted
and it's a really
kind of sweet funny
moment of elation pascal i have to tell
you i have
joyfully watched you on one calls the
heart for years but goodness you made me
reach for the kleenex box more in this
episode than any episode i've ever
watched the first time you made me cry
uh was the scene in the infirmary
you might be pregnant
well that's the funniest thing with this
in it actually sounded like you said
pregnant i did
i i think i need to lie down
[Music]
after all this time
was it always your plan to keep rosemary
reserved throughout this process because
we're so used to her being the comedic
relief in the room and to see her
reaction i have to tell you it surprised
me
you know i've always thought and what i
think we've seen over and over again is
the bigger the life moment the smaller
rosemary gets and so
that made perfect sense to me that
it would be as small as possible
those moments when lee was in the
infirmary and she was at his bedside
like those were those are really small
moments and i i always thought that that
was an i've always thought that that's
an interesting juxtaposition in her
character that the biggest moments get
she becomes the smallest and i love it i
think that that's real
so the second time that i cried in the
episode is when rosemary tells elizabeth
that she's expecting
you even have pink cheeks you look like
you're glowing
[Music]
rosemary
i was trying to tell you
yes maybe
possibly
and my goodness you and your good friend
erin cracow there are tears in both your
eyes
what was it like sharing such an
emotional scene together i knew it was
going to be really special but
it um
you know it caught me off guard because
she's
she was so emotional in such a beautiful
way and i just think it's such a
testament to
their friendship and how close those two
really are they really are you know have
each other's back for everything and
wanting to share in every single moment
good and bad and everything in between
we've got two more episodes left in the
season
what can you tease about what's to come
there are still a lot of unexpected
twists and turns to this story it's just
still an unexpected journey that is
unfolding it's not just
yay we're pregnant
and here we go
there's a lot of twists and turns and
it's not totally smooth i would also say
that it's not really over after the two
episodes either the twists and turns
that are being established over the next
two episodes
they are still going to be twisting and
turning into season 10 if we're so lucky
yes is lee gonna pick up on any
subtleties or any clues lee's a nice guy
and and i i i love lee but i don't think
he picks up on those little things very
easily i think
this marriage for him has been blunt
force trauma from day one so i think he
needs
large knocks on the head to see the
little small things
so
i think that the best thing you can say
is that when we get to the end of the
season
it's it's going to be an overwhelming
feeling of joy i think for this couple
and it's been a long time coming
so i hope people enjoy it as much as we
enjoyed making it
[Music]
you